Một tâm mấy mô tụt tượng ấn đồ Nga Ren-Dramodit Tên Mô,
mọi đối tổng lên quan đến vụ nổ gần pháu đại đỏ.
Ở tụt đồ như thế lì, sẽ bị truy cứu trinh nghiệp.
Phụ nổ sảy ra tối với mùng mấy tối mô tại khu vực đen sau thông xung hát sma,
khiến mời lắm người thiệt mạng và bác mình ở bị thương,
ở mô đi khẳng đen chính quyền sẽ không quanh yưởng với cảnh vì khu mổ,
và đang hỗ trợ tối đa cho các bạn nhận.
Theo bộ nối của anh đổ, phụ nổ sơ phát từ một chiếc ô tổ đổ khẳng khu dí tích lịch sử,
làm xung chuyển của bực trung tâm thủ đổ.
Ngày sâu đó, hàng loạt băng chính cả nước đặt trong tình trạng báo đậu.
Dởi trước đăng điều trạng mở khả năng, bác gồm gửi vấn,
nhóm cùng bố là Scarlet A, Thế Bà, đứng đằng sau hủ việt.
Một xong hôn tin cho biết vô nổ có thể liên quan đến mạng lối cùng bố,
bị chết phá hôi đấu tháng, trong đó,
lực lượng chính năng đã thu dữ gần bà tấn trên nổ.